ich finde es total geil geboten oder ich
finde es keine quotenfrau zu sein oder
gut ja nicht feiern kann doch nicht
stolz darauf sein will irgendso eines
gesetzes nach oben geschafft so haben es
gibt nichts was mir beweisen würde dass
da keine qualifikation ist und dass dann
frauen da rein gedrängt werden wo sie
gar kein bock bekommen
chef sein bistum deutschlands männer die
traurige wahrheit ist nämlich nur zehn
prozent der unternehmensvorstände sind
bei uns weiblich brauchen wir also eine
frauenquote um endlich auf die 50 50 zu
kommen
die fronten bei 310 fragen sind ziemlich
klar die einen sind sehr dagegen und die
anderen sind sehr dafür
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt und
um ehrlich zu sein glaube ich dass heute
sehr hitzig diskutiert wird mein ziel
ist es natürlich am ende beide seiten
wieder zum kompromiss zu führen
die erste frage die geht aber an euch
was denkt ihr
brauchen wir mehr frauen an der macht
schreibt es mir in die kommentare
die erste runde machen wir jetzt das ist
eine positionierung runde um erstmal
eure position festzustellen und da werde
ich euch jetzt drei fragen stellen die
zweite frage von 13 fragen ist eine
verbindliche 50 50 frauenquote falsch
wenn ihr sagt ja die ist falsch dann
geht ihr ein schritt in richtung gelbes
veltins erste kästchen und wenn er sagt
nein ins grüne feld
eine fifty fifty frauenquote ist wichtig
und richtig weil das ja der idealzustand
wäre den wir hier in unserer
gesellschaft anstreben frauenquote führt
nicht zur gleichberechtigung sie ist ein
symbol politisches strohfeuer das
niemals in der lage sein wird uns
wirklich nachhaltig und dauerhaft zu
helfen nächste frage ist eine
frauenquote diskriminierend männern
gegenüber weil sie den frauen aufgrund
ihres geschlechts einen vorteil
verschafft eine frauenquote ist
diskriminierend gegenüber männern weil
sie natürlich frauen die sagen wir mal
gleich qualifiziert sind oder auch
gleich viel leisten die möglichkeit
geben an den männern vorbei zu ziehen
die realität ist momentan dass männer
unsere welt regieren und sich dagegen zu
stellen ist meiner meinung nach ein sich
in den weg stellen und einen befürworten
von sexistischen nach strukturen nächste
frage spaltet eine frauenquote die
gesellschaft ich finde es hier ist er
aktuell eigentlich unbemerkt eine art
spaltung haben durch die de facto
männerquote die es gibt durch das quasi
patriarchat und daher glaube ich dass
eine frauenquote zu mehr inklusion
führen wird denen die sagen wir brauchen
eine frauenquote jetzt sofort sehen sage
ich das ist viel zu kurz gesprungen und
es ist letztlich auch augenwischerei
weil wir nicht mit ein paar frauen mehr
in vorständen von unternehmen das
problem insgesamt gelöst haben werden
ich würde sagen eure positionen sind
klar wenn ihr gerade zuschaut und euch
denkt ich hätte mich jetzt auch gerne
auf diesem feld positioniert dann
schreib mir doch mal in die kommentare
wo würdet ihr stehen eher auf dem
grünfeld oder auf dem gelben fällt es
geht jetzt in die nächste runde und ab
jetzt versuche ich wieder zu mir hier
ins kompromiss feld zu bringen
und jetzt bedeutet auch wieder
zustimmungen also ja ein schritt auf
mich zu und wenn ihr nicht zustimmt dann
geht er logischerweise einen schritt
nach hinten
ich fange mal bei euch an mit der
frauenquote laufen wir gefahr dass wir
frauen aufgrund ihres geschlechts einen
wirtschaftlichen vorteil verschaffen
aber geschlecht ist natürlich nicht
gleich qualifikationen das wissen wir
alle sollten wir frauen nicht aufgrund
ihrer leistungen fördern anstatt durch
eine quote was sagt ihr
aber da müssen wir erst mal hinkommen
für die diese leistungen wahrzunehmen
und das was ja jetzt auch schon passiert
ist dass männer in position kommt für
die sie vermutlich auch nicht 120
prozent die besten menschen sind und das
ist ja auch in ordnung dass uns doch
erstmal überwiesen common ground
schaffen wo das überhaupt möglich ist
sowieso was sagst du dazu ja ich bin
auch voll deiner meinung weil wir müssen
erst mal dahin kommen dass wir diese
chancengleichheit haben
und abgesehen davon finde ich es immer
so ein bisschen unnötig zu sagen hey
vielleicht ist die frau jetzt überhaupt
nicht qualifiziert genug warum geben wir
dann immer gleich davon aus dass eine
frau nicht qualifiziert ist vielleicht
sollten wir da auch erst mal drüber
nachdenken unsere gedanken da so ein
bisschen nochmal zurechtzurücken weil
jeder und jede hat die chance haben
qualifiziert zu sein dafür
ok dann fast immer zusammen ihr seid
jetzt alle auch nicht so die mega mega
fans davon aber er halte es für ein
gutes mittel zum zweck wolke die nächste
frage geht an euch nur jede fünfte
führungskraft in deutschland ist
weiblich am beispiel medizinstudium sind
wir aber der frauenanteil liegt bei 70
prozent
chefärztin gibt es aber nur knapp zehn
prozent zeigt das nicht dass wir genug
qualifizierte frauen haben und sie durch
die frauenquote an diese wichtigen
position heben müssen wenn ihr mir
zustimmt dann könnt ihr jetzt einen
schritt auf mich zugehen
vor dem ersten teil der frage klar wir
haben gute und viele qualifizierte
frauen weist das beispiel ärztin genannt
aber der zweite teil dass die
frauenquote grad bei den ärztinnen die
dann alle in die chefposition befördert
der ist nicht richtig deswegen habe ich
sozusagen mein fuß welt gestellt
denn meine freundin ist ärztin und die
hat die möglichkeit oberärztin zu werden
aber sie hat drei kleine kinder und sie
sagt ihr könnt mich durch eine quote
nicht zwingen ich will auch meine kinder
noch sehen das heißt also eine quote
würde ihr gar nicht helfen sondern eher
eine möglichkeit auch in teilzeit so
eine chefposition zu haben okay aber die
quote würde ja niemand zwingen diese
position zu kommen es geht eher darum
dass es dann mehr frauen ermöglicht wird
weil sie sind ja offensichtlich da sie
sind da aber viele von denen wünschen
sich einfach bessere rahmenbedingungen
und
die bekommen sie nicht durch eine quote
ja hast du nicht der druck würde sich
erhöhen und dann würden diese
rahmenbedingungen auch eher möglich
gemacht werden
deine frau dein freundin würde
vielleicht nicht gezwungen werden aber
die kollegin von deiner freundin würde
vielleicht denken okay doch jetzt ist
meine zeit
also ich glaube das problem was wir
haben ist dass wir davon ausgehen dass
hier irgendwelche mechanismen am werk
sind die dazu führen dass ihr frauen
systematisch unterdrückt werden und
ihnen nicht der zugang zu diesen höheren
positionen gewährt wird und dass das
ganze dann mit einer quote wir aus
meiner sicht über nicht zu rechtfertigen
ist dann irgendwie korrigiert werden
soll
aber ich glaube wir müssen doch einfach
mal zumindest den gedanken zu lassen das
ist eine freie entscheidung ist so
vieler frauen dass sie sagen hey mir ist
persönliches wichtig eine balance zu
finden zwischen meinem berufsleben und
meinem familienleben und dann möchte ich
mich nicht beispielsweise in so ein
haifischbecken darum hinbegeben mit 70
stunden woche wir sind andere dinge eben
auch wichtig also denkst du robin was
fragen gar nicht in die oberste etage
wollen zumindest nicht auf in breiter
masse ich glaube einige frauen wollen da
ganz sicher hin
und die kommen auch dahin und ich glaube
auch dass wenn frauen sich dazu
entscheiden karriere machen zu wollen
dass sie geradezu protegiert werden also
ich glaube einfach wenn man sich einmal
der vorstandes landschaft mit deutschen
umschaut dann hat man eigentlich auf der
einen seite extremes diversität problems
anzahl den homogenisiert das problem und
zwar wenn man sich mal die profile von
den vorstand vorständen anschaut dann
sind die in der regel entweder halten
sie michaela thomas sind anfang 50 und
am ende der
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen background
oder in den ingenieurs background und
ich glaube der trend hat einfach gezeigt
in der praxis dass diese menschen eben
eher dazu tendieren menschen mit
ähnlichem profil background
westdeutschen einstellen
und ich glaube wenn man das ganze jetzt
überträgt auf das recruiting von frauen
dann sieht man einfach da es ein
extremes systemisches problem hier
verankert
das wird unterstellt dass wissen werden
ich glaube wir müssen noch mal kurz zu
der frage zurück ist die frauenquote
denn überhaupt das effizienteste mittel
was wir in der hand haben um dieses
problem der mangelnden diversität
überhaupt zu lösen
und wenn man sich jetzt mal alle
entwürfe anguckt die realistisch sind
dass man sie in den nächsten fünf bis
zehn jahren durch bekommt dann
betreffen alle diese entwürfe so umgeht
90 bis 100 vielleicht 110 unternehmen
das sind börsennotierte unternehmen die
paritätisch mit bestimmt werden das ist
alles worüber wir reden und daran macht
sich der ganze streit fest wird der
staat hätte zigmal effizientere
möglichkeiten gesamtgesellschaftlich die
probleme anzugehen und die frauenquote
ist so ein mittel was vielen leuten
angst macht auch einigen leuten hoffnung
macht und beides ist überhaupt nicht
berechtigt weil sie am ende nicht hält
was sie verspricht aber kompromisse sind
doch immer super also warum kann man
denn nicht beides zusammen machen warum
geht ihr nicht eine frauenquote
warum für also eine frankfurter um sie
einzuführen um sie irgendwann wieder
dann auch absetzen zu können und
gleichzeitig andere instrumente mit
einzuführen weil die erfahrungen der
vergangenheit gezeigt hat dass sobald
man irgendwas für frauenförderung
gemacht hat dann erst mal gesagt wird
bei allen weiteren projekten die viel
sinnvoller wären ja wir haben ja jetzt
schon eine frauenquote eingeführt jetzt
müssen wir erst mal gucken ob das
überhaupt was bringt und wenn wir uns
die entwicklung der vergangenheit
angucken und das hochrechnen wie sich
die vorstände entwickeln dann geht man
davon aus dass wenn das wachstum der
frauen gleich bleibt wir in 22 jahren
eine 40 60 verteilung hätten
ich bin der meinung es nur in china hin
ja aber es lohnt sich auf dieses
organische wachstum sozusagen zu warten
weil das spiegelt dann auch tatsächlich
ein umdenken in den unternehmen wider
und ist eben nicht nur der chor samt dem
staat gegenüber weil man es halt muss
maria glaubst du dass wir einfach nur
ganz doll die daumen drücken müssen und
warten müssen und dann wird sich das
problem schon von alan ada keinen fall
weil das hat halt bisher auch nicht
geklappt also ja das hat jetzt geklappt
weil wir jetzt 30 70 oder sogar bisher
mehr haben es hat funktioniert ja
tatsächlich diese quote in
aufsichtsräten überhaupt erst
einzuführen und kommunen sowie reden
darüber 30 70 das immer noch voll loso
ja lasst uns 40 60 machen und lasst uns
das zu lassen jetzt hat die erfahrung
gezeigt es läuft gut also warum nicht
weiter gehen und da wo wir die
freiwilligkeit haben wollen zb in den
vorständen klappts eben dich wo sind wir
dabei 89 prozent oder so was ist das
denn kann mir keiner erzählen dass da
niemand haben wollte ich immer maria ich
stimme dir zu
das kann nicht sein dass wir bei 89
prozent frauen in vorständen bleiben das
ist peinlich das geht gar nicht
aber das thema ist ja viel
vielschichtiger meine sorge ist dass man
sozusagen aus der politik macht man
gesetz quote vorstände thema erledigt
haken check und das ist das schlimmste
eigentlich was den frauen
in der frage der chancengerechtigkeit
eigentlich passieren kann
war das thema damit einem gesetz
abgehakt ist aber wie immer ist ja schon
sagt das ist ja viel vielschichtiger
es geht ja nicht nur um die thomas gegen
sozusagen eine kerstin sondern es geht
auch um den thomas der westdeutsch ist
und das sozusagen auch
unterrepräsentiert ostdeutsche sind es
geht um menschen mit
migrationshintergrund die beiden
thomassen auch eigentlich keine rolle
spielen das heißt also das ist ein viel
tiefer gehendes thema und wer meint wir
machen mal eben so ein quoten gesetz der
täuscht sich in der frage dass damit
jetzt sozusagen die frauenfrage geklärt
ist die politik wird sich dann
zurücklehnen und das finde ich schade
aber das war gar nichts dafür tief in
uns verankert eigentlich so ganz feste
denkmuster einfach haben die es gilt
einfach mal aufzulösen ja also ich frage
mich immer auch mein heranwachsende
treckern und einschnitte auf ihn
zukommen wir abstimmen soll
wenn ich an meine tochter denke sagen
die hat es den ersten arbeitstag und
zieht da sozusagen schaut in die
chefetage sieht da lauter männer glaubt
ihr nicht
ich hatte das gar nicht für möglich
dahin zu kommen das geht eigentlich gar
nicht und müssen wir da nicht eigentlich
jetzt mal sagen etwas in die richtige
richtung rücken um sage ich mal mehr
raum zu schaffen für diesen neuen
rollenmodelle und die sozusagen auch zu
leben ob ich muss noch mal versuchen
dieses thema quote in frage zu stellen
also ich glaub quoten lassen sich nur
rechtfertigen wenn wir hier ein gesetz
gegen also ich verstoß gegen das
grundgesetz irgendwie sehen oder unser
volk bedroht ist dann kann man eine
quote einführen und quoten sind
brandgefährlich das wollte ich euch
nochmal aber kann ich mal ganz ehrlich
miteinander das ist noch wichtig das
möchte ich unbedingt zu ende bringt es
mir ganz wichtig quoten sind
brandgefährlich warum weil quoten immer
mit gruppen einhergehen das heißt wir
spalten unsere gesellschaft in männer
und frauen und diese gruppen identitäten
kommen an die spitze das individuum wird
herabgestuft verschwindet dahinter ist
nicht mehr wichtig wer du bist sondern
es nur noch wichtig dass du teil dieser
gruppen identität wird und dann zweiter
punkt dahinter wenn dann diese gruppen
erst mal entstehen dann betonen diese
gruppen ja innerhalb der gesellschaft
nicht mehr so zu sagen hey wir sind alle
eins sondern wissen unterschiedlich wir
teilen uns ist betont nicht mehr das
gemeinsame nicht mehr das vereinende
sondern das trennende
letzter punkt dritter punkt auch ganz
wichtig wenn diese gruppen erst mal
diese gruppen erstmal geschaffen wurden
dann ist es ganz leicht
schuldzuweisungen zu machen zu
diffamieren auszugrenzen und es ist kein
zufall dass die größen crude ihrer der
weltgeschichte stalin mao und hitler
heißen
okay das ist jetzt ein bisschen
überheblich solchen ich möchte einfach
mal auf das brandgefährlich zurückkehren
weil ich das gefährlich würde das
eigentlich in einen topf mit der
frauenquote zu werfen und möchte ich
noch mal fragen hast du das gefühl dass
seit 2005 10 wo für börsennotierte
unternehmen das in aufsichtsräten
eingeführt wurde und sich ja auch schon
was getan hat dass das jetzt dass das
brandgefährlich jetzt gerade für die
unternehmen geworden ist weil ich finde
dass ich finde dass heftig dass du dass
dieses wort benutzt man aber es ist die
eintrittsschwelle dazu dass wir unsere
gesellschaft spalten in einzelne groß
aber du hast ja da sagt rowley
entwickele ich also hatte hatten auch
wiesen in dieser zeit jetzt dass das
brandgefährlich war also ich doch da
müsste man mal uns genau angucken was in
diesen unternehmen seitdem geschehen ist
noch recht leider unterbrechen es hat
sich auf jeden fall schon ganz schön was
bewegt wir haben jetzt seit wir eine
persönliche runde es geht darum eure
persönliche motivation eure geschichten
kennen zu lernen und zu verstehen warum
steht ihr da wo er gerade steht und
deswegen richtig erst mal die frage an
euch welche erfahrungen habt jeder
gemacht wurde tier schon mal aufgrund
ihres geschlechts diskriminiert dann
schreibt es mir sehr gerne in die
kommentare
luisa erst kürzlich mit einem video und
dem hashtag ich will an die
bundesregierung appelliert dass endlich
eine verpflichtende frauenquote in
unternehmen eingeführt wird warum reicht
dann eine freiwillige quote nicht aus
weil wir gemerkt haben dass ich durch
diese freiwillige selbstverpflichtung
einfach nichts geändert hat und wenn ich
so daran denke wir haben generationen
die noch nach uns kommen ja und da sind
also übrigens wenn wir über die
frankfurter reden hoffe ich dass jedem
der begriff patriarch hat ein begriff
ist und sich gut also wenn aber also ich
hoffe du akzeptierst es auch dass es
immer auch der fall ist dass diese
strukturen einfach vorhanden sind und
das gilt es ja das aufzubrechen und ich
möchte für meine kinder und für alle
generationen diese nachkommen und
besonders auch für mädels einfach
dieselben chancen haben wie die für
männer nämlich dass sie vorbilder haben
in höheren positionen und sich denken ja
das kann nicht schaffen und genauso ging
es einen prominenten die in diesem video
mit gemacht haben und dass wir in der
wilden schritt auf ihn zu geil
deswegen finde ich das total wichtig und
da steht ja auch total hinter ihr könnt
euch jetzt gerne dazu positionieren du
hast dich schon bewegt wie auch einen
schritt nach vorne ist findet auf jeden
fall wichtig role models sind unheimlich
wichtig ich kann mich aber nicht
erinnern und glaube auch es hat sich
nicht so viel getan seit ich in der
berufsfindungsphase war dass man sich
erstmal durchblättert wer ist denn
gerade im vorstand von welchem
unternehmen und sagt also das ist
wirklich so ein vorbild wir haben wir
haben frauen in führungspositionen wir
haben angela merkel wir haben ursula von
der leyen
wir haben christine lagarde gehabt also
das gibt ja schon im politischen bereich
oder in bereichen die die auch sichtbar
sind für mädchen gibt es ja schon solche
erfolgsmodelle und ich glaube es ist
auch unglaublich wertvoll dass diese
diese position gerade gegen den
widerstand von einem patriarchats
errungen wurden das macht sie noch
wertvoller das macht es noch viel
erstrebenswerte das auch zu schaffen und
ich weiß nicht ob gerade dieser vorbild
charakter so ein bisschen verloren geht
wenn man weiss ja okay die hat die
position bekommen weil irgendein frau
mussten sie nehmen also weiß ich nicht
ich finde das ist tschuldigung eine
sache noch dazu ich finde es total geile
quoten oder ich finde es keine
quotenfrau zu sein oder gut ja nicht so
war ja weil ich dafür sorgen kann dass
eben gerade diese mädels bei den du
sagst du gucken dann durch den katalog
warte und die puppen ja nicht durch den
katalog heutzutage sondern durch
instagram linkedin und ganz viele
portale wo ihn tausende beispiele und
möglichkeiten gezeigt wenn es etwas ganz
anderes als früher du wirst die ganze
zeit damit konfrontiert und da finde ich
es einfach sei wichtig dass es diese
vorbilder gibt und dann klappt ich
glaube wir haben trotzdem auf sein man
kann auch nicht stolz darauf sein will
irgendso eines gesetzes nach oben
geschafft so haben muss ich leistung es
muss ich leiste durch wenden männer die
auf einem regionalproporz von
irgendwelche aus irgendwelchen anderen
grund im übrigen auch in vorständen ich
war ja neun jahre lang im unternehmen
tätig nicht im vorstand
aber da gibt es so viele gründe warum
man denn einen vorstand kommt kein man
schämt sich dafür dass er da rein
gekommen ist weil er sozusagen
ich sag mal der einzige dann war die man
gefunden um aus deutschland zu
integrieren und talentförderung und
unternehmenskultur arbeiten damit
überhaupt welche da sind die da meinen
vorstand gehen können also auf jeden
fall was hat denn eine welt die nur von
männern regiert wird für auswirkungen
für frauen luisa allein schon also wenn
jetzt eine welt nur von männern regiert
wird wo komme ich dann davor also wie
kann wie groß mein ansporn mich als frau
dann weiter zu entwickeln wenn ich sehe
ich finde da überhaupt nicht statt und
habe keine chance und genauso ein
vorstand finde ich eigentlich total
wichtig dass es da männer und frauen
gibt weil ist ja nun mal auch so ist das
eine frau vielleicht ganz anders
empathie nach außen aus schreit oder
noch mal eine ganz andere sachen denkt
und davon profitieren dann alle in
diesem unternehmen und wahrscheinlich
jetzt endlich dann auch die diversity
die da stattfindet also deswegen zweifle
ich auch dabei rein wissenschaftlich
regensburger es gibt ja studien dazu was
sozusagen wir wollen also ich möchte
gerne vielfalt in unternehmen in der
politik in der verwaltung in der
gesellschaft gelebte vielfalt die
interessante frage ist nur welches
unternehmen schafft es sozusagen
tatsächlich diese vielfalt zu leben und
dazu gibt studien die sagen entscheidend
ist doch die unternehmenskultur da wo du
dann im umkehrschluss viele frauen hast
die auch in führungspositionen sind die
sind von ihrer unternehmenskultur offen
die lassen anderes zu verschiedene
sichtweisen zu und du kannst ein stock
konservatives unternehmen haben die
setzen dann der drei frauen mehr im
vorstand hin sagen es ist okay machen
wir das seit und gleichzeitig die
unternehmens atmosphäre so was von nicht
offen da werden keine nachkommen da
werden die dann verhungern die anders
sind sozusagen als die norm im
unternehmen deswegen ist die kultur ein
entscheidender faktor und das kriegst du
nicht per zwang hin brabbeln du bist
sehr stark gegen die frankfurter das
heißt sie ja schon klar gemacht du
glaubst sogar dass die frauen schaden
würde warum also nicht nur frau
entscheidet sich erst mal schaut sie
natürlich auch erstmal den männern also
wenn man dann
ein einigermaßen leistungs gleiche
menschen hätte ja und es geht darum
innerhalb des unternehmens sozusagen zu
entscheiden werden macht jetzt sozusagen
den nächsten schritt dann darf das
geschlecht keine rolle spielen darf sich
nur leistungen entsprechen diese
entscheidung einfließen lassen ja das
ist das wichtigste und zweitens schadet
sie auch den frauen war schon ein
bisschen angedeutet hier mit verhungern
lassen den oberen positionen sie
diskreditiert natürlich die frauen wenn
da oben im top-management frauen
reingeschossen werden die plötzlich da
sind wegen der quote ja die haben den
quoten stempel drauf dann ist die da
wegen der quote aber doch nicht weil
sich durch leistung darum hin
qualifizierter die wie dementsprechend
nicht ernst genommen und wird
wahrscheinlich nach oben möglicherweise
aufbauen
ihr habt euch alle nach hinten bewegt
warum alle hoffen weil das so klingt als
gelb ist keine qualifikation wenn danach
gefragt wird und das stimmt einfach
nicht und das gefühl dass vermittelt
wird ist dass frauen eher dann gezwungen
werden zu etwas was sie nicht wollen
nichts belegt dass so momentan sind die
ergebnisse gut gewesen bei den
aufsichtsräten lasst uns das bitte
weiter fortführen um dann auch die
strukturen in den unternehmen den druck
im unternehmen zu erhöhen
es gibt nichts was mir beweisen würde
dass da keine qualifikation ist und dass
sich das frauen das dann frauen da rein
gedrängt werden wo sie gar kein bock
darauf haben was ich vermisse bei der
quotendiskussion ist und man macht sich
eigentlich nicht die mühe die reformen
einzufordern die in der unternehmens
aber auch in der politik welt in der
verwaltungs welt dringend erforderlich
sind und noch mal der staat muster
vorangehen er muss in der verwaltung zu
sagen wo gibt es eigentlich in einem
bundesministerium wobei an vorderster
front irgendwie jobsharing gemacht wird
wo sich zwei
die positionen scheinen es ist ein
verkrustetes denken dass man in teilzeit
oder wenn man sich flexibler die zeit
einteilen muss nicht für karriere
gemacht ist und das ist in allen
bereichen so krass da muss man ansetzen
wie viel stimme die auch zu dass wenn
wir die frankfurter einführen das dann
nicht damit alles erledigt sein kann
aber ich finde es einen enormen
fortschritt dass politiker wie olaf
scholz oder ein markus söder für eine
frauenquote sind weil das auch immer
noch ja du lachst wieder aber das hat
auch was mit dem thema feminismus zu tun
und ich finds halt ein bisschen schade
dass eigentlich die ganze zeit nur last
weil ich das gefühl habe du weißt gar
nicht wie es manchmal für frauen
eigentlich heutzutage immer noch ist
sich durchboxen zu müssen
sein verhalten spiegelt sich in den
ganzen in den ganzen panels in denen ich
sitze oft nur mit männern total wieder
die nehme ich nicht für voll mit meiner
mama in punkten
das glaube ich erst wenn die csu und die
union das im wahlprogramm hat ich aber
das ist war kam ganz er wissen wir alles
selber und olaf scholz dafür sind ist
doch schon der erste schritt um ganz
ganz vorsichtig zu werden weil einer
frauenquote die die zustimmen die will
ich nicht sehen wie effizient die rist
und das ist wirklich damit ist der
wahlkampf eröffnet aber die
gleichberechtigung bestimmten erwarten
warum ist ihr dann dieses thema so
wichtig hast du so dollar angst dass die
frauenquote dich in deinem alltag oder
in deiner karriere ein schreiner ich
glaube dass es ein anschlag auf unsere
freiheit ist und das ist auch die
freiheit der arena das ja auch kleiner
ist ein anschlag auf uns unsere alle
freiheit glaube ich tatsächlich ja ich
glaube uns ich glaube dass dieses ganze
thema am wirklichen problem vorbeigeht
ich glaube dieser mit dieser frauenquote
geht es um macht und es geht nicht um
die frauen wenn es wirklich um die
frauen ginge dann müssen wir uns mal den
fundamentalen unterschied zwischen
männern und frauen ansehen und das ist
nun mal der unterschied dass frauen
kinder bekommen ja wenn der lift ja und
frauen in diesen schwung nicht einfach
benachteiligt werden dadurch und wir
müssen eigentlich klar wir investieren
dass frauen in der lage werden das
irgendwie durch teilzeitmodelle bessere
kita versorgung und so weiter irgendwie
zu harmonisieren anstatt einfach eine
quote von e mails zu setzen
ich bin entsetzt waren ein teil ist
entsetzt
aber das heißt die müssen wir da nicht
eigentlich nach vorne laufen weil ihm
weiß ich nicht bin gerade irgendwie ich
musste jetzt mal darauf reagieren das
geht so gar nicht also vereinbarkeit von
familie beruf gehen ja nicht nur die
frauen was anders ist ja eine sache von
manager und habe ich mich wieder hinten
so dass man zum punkt hinkommen dass es
viel selbstverständlicher wird dass auch
männer elternzeit nehmen und das ist
doch das thema wir haben immer noch
hürden
dies anscheinend und auch statistisch
belegt frauen in den weg stellt diesen
weg zu gehen jetzt ist die interessante
frage wie kriegen wir diese hürden weg
und welche sind das ja aber auf dem
flugfeld ist es die quote wir sind uns
einig anders sind eigentlich einig das
sind auch andere themen aber sozusagen
das jetzt so zu reduzieren männer und
frauen sind halt unterschiedlich da bin
ich selbst griechischen stadt geholt
aber die unterbrechen
ich glaub ich glaube punkt ist klar
geworden maria ich möchte ganz zu dir
kommen du versuchst bei eurem format auf
klo die frauenquote oben zu halten
warum ist das so wichtig wir reden hier
nicht nur von frauen und männern wir
eben von verschiedener geschlechter
vielfalt wir streben von vielfalt was
die sexuelle orientierung was man sich
mit migrationshintergrund und wenn ich
mit rassismus erfahrungen angeht wir
wollen mit menschen sprechen die wissen
wie es ist mit diskriminiert wegen ihrer
behinderung zu werden und das muss
tatsächlich gelebte diversität geht sein
dann gehe ich auch wirklich mit ihr geht
es nicht um kosmetik sondern hier geht
es um wirklich entscheidungen treffen
und da geht es auch darum wenn es mal
darum geht war scheiße wir suchen eine
kamera person und wir finden gerade
keine frau oder wie auch in diesen mint
bereichen oder so dann geht's halt mal
darum länger zu suchen
mit mehr leuten zu sprechen und das
lohnt sich einfach für sich verdammten
dann aber ich wurde nicht belästigt bei
der arbeit ich werde es ausgeht ich kann
ausreden bei der arbeit seien
unglaublich warmes und unglaublich
professionell ist umfeld und in dem
moment habe ich das gefühl wir über
frauenquote sprechen und so tun als
ginge es darum vielfalt da versperren
wir uns ist jetzt nur eine annahme um
über diese vielen anderen auch um
strukturelle sachen zu reden aber eben
auch um wirklich diversität zu sprechen
und über menschen zu sprechen die
benachteiligt sind in unserer
gesellschaft mehr als nur dass die
sexismus erfahren sondern zum beispiel
rassismus und das lohnt sich anzugehen
warum ist es dir dann so wichtig da ist
jemand einen schritt nach warum
na ja also ich bin das ist ja ein hehres
ziel und das kann man ja auch durchaus
verfolgen nicht unbedingt der quote aber
an diesem teilaspekt würde ich da auch
zustimmen wenn ich nach wie vor der
meinung leistung muss sich da
durchsetzen also es ist muss eigentlich
völlig egal sein
welches geschlecht welche rasse welche
hafer weil irgendjemand hat solange
diese leistung die diese person zu
diesen unternehmen beiträgt muss diese
person dann einfach eingestellt werden
unabhängig von irgendwelchen ideologien
im hintergrund und das ist richtig
spannend war
gut dass du sagst denn ich habe das
gemacht ich habe jetzt ein jahr lang
anonyme bewerbungsverfahren durchlebt
und ich habe drei menschen eingestellt
zusammen mit meinem team in
anonymisierten bewerbungsverfahren
bedeutet nur im ersten schritt ist so
weit wie möglich alles geschwärzt und
wir wissen nicht welches geschlecht da
kommt wir wissen wenn jemand nicht
schreiben was für eine sprache die
person spricht oder in welchem land
zimmer studiert hat wissen wir nicht wo
diese person geboren ist und das hat
tatsächlich dazu gebracht dass wir zum
einen auch cis männer eingestellt haben
und diese erste hürde dazu geführt hat
dass uns das natürlich nicht abschreckt
und damit eine was kommt denn da jetzt
und das führt auch dazu dass man einfach
erstmal im ersten moment einen klaren
blick auf die welt hat nämlich mit dem
bewusstsein dass soziale ungerechtigkeit
mehr ist als du kannst alles schaffen
und mit der richtigen qualifikation
kommst du da schon hin weil du musst
diese qualifikation erst mal bekommen
denn eltern müssen sie diese nachricht
nachhilfe bezahlt haben denn soziale
umfeld muss irgendwie an geld gehabt
haben die ich auf irgend eine tolle
reise in new york zum advents steuern
reden wir doch nicht über eine quote wir
reden über die bedingungen der
möglichkeit aber wir müssen daran
glauben dass es da mehr darum geht als
nur was in deinem lebenslauf steht
sondern ich sehe einen lebenslauf ich
hab kein geschlecht gesehen ich muss
diesen lebenslauf lesen und dann mit der
person sprechen und da kommt viel mehr
aus als nur irgendwie studium und was
die person mitgebracht hat franziska du
sagst ganz klar ich will keine
quotenfrau sein warum
ja weil ich immer das gefühl hat das ist
ein malus den man dann ja generation
spies mit sich rumschleppt da die frau
wäre nicht eingestellt wurden wäre ich
nicht vorher eingestellt würden ich wäre
nicht eingestellt wurden hättest dieses
gesetz nicht gegeben das heißt das
können wir theoretisch immer weiter
denken und so bleibt zu dieser dieser
kleine makel an einer gleichberechtigung
wenn sie dann irgendwann mal kommt dass
man gesagt hat ja wir mussten erst es
musste erst der start kommen ja weil es
von von offensichtlich
gesamtgesellschaftlich es nicht in die
köpfe zu bekommen war dass es eine gute
möglichkeit ist sich divers aufzustellen
oder es einfach nicht zu verhindern das
ist irgendwo auch und sich eingestehen
gescheitert zu sein anders ich würde
gerne zu dir kommen weil du bist nämlich
gründer du bist unternehmer im startup
bereich und er achtet sehr darauf viele
frauen einzustellen was sind denn da
deine erfahrung mit dem bewerb erinnern
ja was ich eigentlich total spannend
finden sozusagen ist das
bewerbungsverfahren und top
sinfonieorchester in
in den usa haben einfach ein quoten
problem gehabt haben fünf prozent
frauenanteil gehabt und dann haben sie
ein experiment gestartet nachdem
plötzlich die das vorspielen hinter
verschlossenen vorhängen gemacht und
plötzlich ist sozusagen die frauenquote
nach oben gegangen und und da daran
sieht man glaube ich so ein bisschen
dass sie einfach doch irgendwie
unterliegen einfach ins systemisches
problem haben und ich glaube dass keiner
vorgeschützt wir haben alle gewisse
rollenmodelle so zeigen auch im kopf und
ich erlebe zum beispiel auch in der
realität tendenziell wenn man in die
bewerbung ausgesprochen kommt ein vier
großen räder anteil der erzählt vielmehr
fakt ist vielmehr im verkaufs mode
während frauen tendenziell eher so ein
bisschen defensiver sozusagen
kommunizieren und gerade für
führungspositionen muss man halt
wirklich aufpassen dass einem nicht
irgend ein potenzielles talent
eigentlich entgeht weil man denkt der
hat sich jetzt aber besser verkauft
während vielleicht der man vielleicht
eher mittelmäßiger war und die frau gar
nicht richtig verkaufen konnte oder es
vielleicht nicht so etabliert ist ja im
rollenverständnis an die frauen unter
euch wie geht es euch habt ihr manchmal
das gefühl dass ihr selbstwertgefühl
oder selbstbewusstsein in
bewerbungsgesprächen fehlt und genau das
euch daran hindert erfolgreich zu werden
oder in wichtige position zu kommen
fairere bewerbungsgespräche stimmt er
dazu und geht einen schritt auf ihn zu
grundsätzlich auf jeden fall aber auch
damit ist es nicht getan weil es liegt
nicht nur am es liegt nur an der
unternehmensseite dass frauen sich im
bewerbungsgespräch anders präsentieren
das sind die vielschichtige ursachen die
in der familie schon beginnen und die in
der erziehung beginnen wie gehen lehrer
mit einem kind um und so weiter und so
fort
das sind verschiedene sachen das
netzwerk ist so wichtig dass sich frauen
zusammen tun und wirklich mal rangehen
wie führen wir denn bewerbungsgespräch
wie wie treten wir denn auch in diesen
verkaufsmodus weil es nützt nämlich
nichts wenn das nicht erfolgt ist und
dann sind im vorstand auf einmal frauen
die die vielleicht die schlimmsten
ängste von den wänden die da sitzen
bestätigen weil sie durch dieses durch
dieses
netzwerk gar nicht durchgegangen sind
was was mir naja alles im hintergrund
haben was man ja gar nicht sieht und ich
glaube wir müssen erstmal da uns ein
bisschen was von der von den
seilschaften der männer abkommen ein
angst ist da dass wir die maskulinen
attribute idealisieren und sagen macht
mal und klar netzwerke cool so aber dann
heißt auf jahr macht mal unterbrechen
oder sitzt breitbeinig irgendwann im
büro damit die genug leute zu hören
meine angst ist wenn man auf die
freiwilligkeit dann sei es geht ja
glaube ich so ein bisschen in die
richtung dass wir dann so tun als
müssten die die vom system benachteiligt
wurden sind sich bitte selber erheben
soja macht mal so ihr könnt doch warum
macht ihr es nicht so und das reicht mir
nicht so ganz okay ihr seid gerade schon
sehr lösungs freudig deswegen würde ich
einfach die nächste runde einläuten und
zwar die lösungs runde drei vorschläge
für euch drei kompromissvorschläge und
ich bin mal gespannt wer die findet
elfte frage von 13 fragen können wir uns
alle darauf einigen dass wir eigentlich
kein bock auf die frauenquote haben aber
sie brauchen um überhaupt mal was zu
ändern
hier habe ich noch sagen beweg der
schwank so dahin wird es weg weil ich
durch die million da kriegen wir uns
noch nicht zwölfte frage von 13 fragen
können wir uns darauf einigen dass jedes
unternehmen das eine frauenquote von 50
prozent in den führungsetagen nicht
erreicht oder nicht erreichen will
eine ausgleichszahlung machen muss und
mit diesen geldern würden wir dann
andere gleichstellungsmaßnahmen im bund
finanzieren also ich finde man muss
immer noch klar sagen hey das ist
private wirtschaft da hat der staat
nichts herumzufummeln wir finanzieren
diesen staat mit diesen steuergeldern
der soll nicht reinwaschen zum einen
finde also dieses 50 50 quote ist je
nach branche und nach nach unternehmen
auch überhaupt nicht dass das es
widerspiegelt wie das unternehmen
aufgebaut ist und das ist halt einfach
bei tech unternehmen oder bei
informatikunternehmen wäre es würde es
überhaupt nicht die lebenswirklichkeit
eben unternehmen wieder spielt also von
daher hatte da wird häufig vergessen
dass er voll oft in zum beispiel
besonders aufsichtsräten aber auch in
führungspositionen gar nicht die
menschen sind die das dann selber
studieren mussten oder die eben gerade
mint-berufe vorher ausgeführt haben dann
zum beispiel juristen und juristinnen
und davon gibt's total viele besonders
wenn man sich international umschaut und
das würde sich total lohnen da mal
bisher in den blick bitte weiter zu
ziehen
also ich glaube gerade wenn es um in
form
ja aber der auch selbst im tecdax
unternehmen ich glaube ja es gibt zu
wenig sage ich mal ingenieurnachwuchs
quasi aber ich glaube gerade für die
führungsposition
da glaube ich dass es einfach gleich auf
es hat gibt es genauso gute
qualifizierte frauen die eine
führungsposition sage ich mal besetzen
können an der an der stelle ist also
nicht gleich dass sie alle hinwollen
aber ab dass es sie gibt absolut okay
dreizehnte frage von 13 fragen viele
eltern müssen aus finanziellen gründen
zwei vollzeitjobs stemmen kroner zeigt
jetzt aber wenn es hart auf hart kommt
dann bleibt die frau zu hause müssen wir
uns also nicht vielleicht er statt einer
frauenquote um eine familien quote
bemühen die genau dafür sorgt dass man
eltern sein kann und karriere macht
damit tun wir so als würde jede familie
aus meiner frau bestehen ich als nicht
heterosexuelle frau ich werde
wahrscheinlich keinen mann heiraten ich
werde wahrscheinlich eine familie
gründen mit einer frau und ich sehe mich
da überhaupt nicht egal ob familie ist
das also meines verständnis nach da wo
kinder sind egal ob mir nach frauen
welcher kombination auch immer wird
sagen er wieder der zusatz oder an das
wäre wären wir die ganze zeit über die
verschiedensten instrumente maßnahmen
gesprochen
und wenn wir das eine mit dem anderen
rein können bombastisch nachrichten
alternativ waters weg vom steuer und
innovativ und kann es damit gern
versuchen die die andere endlich tier
damit leben wenn unternehmen
zielvereinbarungen eingehen was sie ja
jetzt auch schon machen aber ohne zieht
die zielgröße 0 sondern sich verbessern
müssten in ihrem anteil an frauen aber
auch an anderen menschen mit anderen
hinter ja aber zielgröße eins ist schon
auch weniger also nicht darum gehen
welche zielgruppe sondern als der sohn
als zielgröße +11 sondern es ist wie ja
und noch wollt ihr euch verbessere aber
bei manchen kontinuierlich verbessert
und sagen okay ziel erreicht nächstes
ziel also eine pause nicht stehen
sondern bestehende also dass so ein
system
ich sehe hier viele nicken jetzt
eigentlich doppeln konnten du kannst
jetzt auch mal bisschen nach vorne
kommen
was würde denn passieren wenn sie die
zielgrößen nämlich einheiten mit dem und
ja das ist eine spannende freiheit ist
muss auf jeden fall strafzahlungen geben
sag ich mal wenn wenn nicht eingehalten
wird und diese strafzahlungen sollten
vielleicht in die etablierung von
kontrast der eu typen investiert werden
also dass gerade sogar hin dass
sozialisierung von von von jungen
kindern
tendenziell eben auch es mehr
feuerwehrfrauen sozusagen gibt und
präsidentinnen und krankenpfleger das
wäre mein wunsch mit blick auf was sie
tagtäglich mit meinen eigenen kindern
erleben tier dazu doch kann der staat
auch selber schon machen dann aber dann
haben wir jetzt das ist eine alternative
lösungsvorschlag das nicht cool das neue
das gab es noch nie also ich glaube was
ich jetzt festgestellt habe wenn man die
frauenquote wirklich als ein element
ganz ganz vielen maßnahmen nimmt was nur
was nur ein aspekt ist und es dann so
vielen menschen so wichtig es ist dann
wäre es tatsächlich etwas womit ich
leben könnte
ja solange eben alles zusammen passiert
so und ich glaube das ist das was ich es
vorher nicht gedacht hätte dass ich mit
dieser position jetzt ausgehe aus dem
gespräch ich fühle mich gerade wohl war
das total ein super gefühl ist
an ganz verschiedenen standpunkten zu
starten und dann aber in der mitte zu
enden ich kann aber auch nicht
ignorieren dass ein gesprächs plus wie
zum beispiel von so einem
diskussionsteilnehmer wie robin mich
emotional macht mich auch aufregt und
zwischendurch mich irgendwie zu ganz
wilden gesichts kirmes bringen weil es
schon hart es in manchen situationen
unterbrochen zu werden oder eben von
männern gesagt zu bekommen wie frauen
sich arbeitet und damit damit muss ich
noch ein bisschen habe ich ein bisschen
mit zu tun als man gegen die frauenquote
zu sein steht man ja immer so unter
generalverdacht man hätte so irgendwie
was gegen die frau und sozusagen und
möchte sie irgendwie so an den karren
pinke überhaupt nicht also ich bin
großer fan von frauen auch ein
unternehmen das mittel kommt man ganz
deutlich sagen aber ich finde es völlig
unmöglich wenn man sagt dass irgendeine
person aufgrund ihres geschlechts
karriere machen soll oder nicht das darf
kein kriterium sein in der wirtschaft
muss sich leistungen auszahlen und
nichts anderes
ich fand es super interessant zu sehen
dass hier die unterschiedlichsten
meinungen stattgefunden haben aber sie
auch ausgehalten wurden man halt
miteinander sprechen konnte und das
finde ich ganz ganz wichtig für alle
bereiche in dem wir leben das man so was
schafft ich nehme noch mal mit
das schon durchaus sein kann dass die
quote eine gewisse anstoß funktion hat
wer diese diversität macht mehr spaß im
arbeitsalltag neue perspektiven
unterschiedliche perspektiven
es ist einfach glaube ich der
bereicherung also ich glaube man sollte
davor auf gar keinen fall irgendwie
irgendwie angst haben was ich heute mal
wieder sehr cool fand ist dass sich
gezeigt hat dass die zwei fronten die
ermöglicht beide sehr stark waren und
auch sehr vehement am anfang
gegeneinander argumentiert haben sich
dann doch in vielen dingen sehr einig
war nur eine frauenquote hat und nicht
also in der umsetzung
deswegen würde mich total interessieren
habt ihr vielleicht noch eine
alternative lösung ein kompromiss dann
schreibt sehr gerne in die kommentare
und schreibt mir auch mal welche
argumente euch heute überzeugt haben ich
hoffe natürlich sehr die folge hat euch
gefallen und falls ja dann würden wir
uns sehr freuen wenn ihr den kanal
abonniert die oben findet ihr ein
weiteres video von 13 fragen und hier
unten gibt es ein weiteres video zum
thema
[Musik]